Speaker 1: Well, this you have to see Herschel
Walker did what was probably not a good idea. He
held a press conference to talk about this scandal
that has surfaced as he is accused by one of the
mothers of one of his children of urging her and
subsequently paying for her to get an abortion
despite claiming to be completely against
abortion, claiming that abortion is murder,
claiming that he is against any exceptions for
abortion, health, life of the mother, incest,
rape, all these different things. And this one was
essentially an abortion of convenience, according
to the mother who said he said it wasn't the right
time for him to be having a baby. He decided to
hold a press conference. And I have to tell you,
this is the most disastrous press conference I
can remember. This is as bad as any Trump press
conference. And I remember when Trump talked
about injecting bleach. Okay. Herschel Walker can
barely speak. And so when you put him in front of
reporters who are going to ask questions,
it's bound to be a disaster. And it was.
I don't even know where to
start. Herschel Walker was asked,
have you now that it has been identified, that
the woman making the claim about the abortion
is one of the mothers of your children? That's
a known number of people. Have you reached out
to one of the mothers to ask them, hey, are you
the one? And he says, no. And the explanation is,
seems like something out of a Dr. Seuss novel.
Speaker 2: Any of the mothers of your children
know to ask why? Why not?
Speaker 3: Why do I need to?
Speaker 2: Well, because, according to the
article, one other woman who says that you
paid for her to have an abortion is also the
mother of one of her children. It seems like
that's that's an easy place.
Speaker 3: Because of the
article. I have more kids.
Speaker 1: Okay. He says because
of the article. I had more kids. What does that
mean? I don't know. An article forced him to have
a child somewhere. The article impregnated
someone with his DNA. What does that mean?
Because of the article, I had more kids.
Speaker 3: That's why I reached out to
you. Why? Because I said no. And that's what
I mean when I say no, as it is not correct.
That's a lie. And that's what I mean.
That's a lie. But if you just let me go.
Speaker 2: Thank you. You said that if this
did happen, there's nothing to be ashamed of.
How do you know this? I mean, this morning.
Speaker 3: I know what I said. I was told.
Speaker 1: He did say that. And I'll have the
clip. So, first of all, he's told you said this
morning in an interview, if this did happen,
it's nothing to be ashamed of. He's like,
I never said that. He did. And
I'll play it for you in a moment.
Speaker 3: Totally different. And if it did
happen, I went out with my ex-wife. She knew
my past. Nothing to do with what this woman
said this this year. The abortion thing is
false. It's a lie. And that's what I said. I
said you didn't have with my ex-wife of what
Christine was talking about. I don't know.
Speaker 1: Okay. So he said. I didn't say
that thing this morning. And yet here he is
saying that thing yesterday morning that it
would be nothing to be ashamed of if it were true.
Speaker 3: I'm saying I've been forgiven because
of all of the things I did when I was in my, you
know, day with my ex-wife and all that and things
I did. I'm not going to do that. I wrote in my
book, I was the guy. I wasn't perfect. I had my
problem with mental health. And I was. I've been
I've been born again. But now I have a new life
and I've been moving forward and everything.
And if that had happened, I would. I would
have said, there's nothing to be ashamed of that.
Speaker 1: If that had happened, I would have said
it because it's nothing to be ashamed of. There
he is himself saying the thing and not exactly
sounding like a guy who has this story straight.
That's for damn sure. And this is one of the worst
candidates, not just this election cycle. This
is one of the worst Senate candidates I have ever
seen. Quite frankly, he should be dropping out of
the race, but he might win. I mean, the voters in
Georgia. Are coming up with so many post-hoc
rationalizations for this. He might actually
win. We'll take a look at what polling looks like
after the weekend. Here's another moment from this
disastrous press conference. He's told, hey, the
lieutenant governor said the only reason you're
even in this thing is because people know you from
football. And he's like, what's the what's that
guy doing now? And they're like, Well, he's the
lieutenant governor and he doesn't seem to get it.
Speaker 4: Herschel, the lieutenant governor,
Geoff Duncan, went on TV, I think last night,
asked very critical words of you saying
that the Republican Party was in disarray.
Speaker 3: I think his direct quote.
Speaker 5: Paraphrasing,
it was the only reason his Republican.
Speaker 4: Nominees, because he scored
a lot of touchdowns for the University.
Speaker 3: Of if you know who did it,
Jeff Duncan. Oh, what is he doing up.
Speaker 2: To the court?
This is so.
Speaker 1: Insane.
Was that guy is the lieutenant governor?
He's like, you know, but what is he doing?
Speaker 3: What is he doing? He's doing work.
For who? Don't go on some TV show. Oh, no, no,
don't you go on TV and talk a lot. You know. No,
don't go on TV and talk a lot right now. You know,
people like that. Do I listen to you know,
people told me I couldn't play football.
Speaker 1: Listen, the. That's true. The
lieutenant, as far as I know, the lieutenant
governor has absolutely no no touchdowns to
his name. That's that that's absolutely true.
What's your reaction to people so close
to you saying you are dishonest like his
own son? Here's his answer to that.
Speaker 2: What's your reaction to
people so close to your son, a mother of
your alleged of someone who says that you,
the mother of your kids saying that
you're lying? What's your reaction
to people so close to you saying don't trust?
Speaker 3: You're just like what I just said.
The Democrats are desperate for the Democrats.
Speaker 1: Oh, God. His son, Christian Walker,
is a devout MAGA Republican. This has nothing to
do with Democrats. It's. I've never seen anything
like this. Who. Who advised him to do this?
Speaker 3: Well, they're they're very
desperate for to see. I love my family.
I always love my family. I'm going to win
this race. I know I'm going to win this race.
Speaker 1: Dear God, what an absolute and total
disaster. I am hopeful that by Monday or Tuesday,
whenever we get the latest polling on this race,
I'm hopeful that this will be essentially over.
Now, if we look at the polling again, we're we're
still waiting on new data. We only have two
polls right now that include any polling
after the start of this scandal. And most of
these polls were still before the scandal,
but it represents about a four point swing in
the direction of Raphael Warnock, as you can see,
sort of before this entire thing scandal,
this this scandal before the scandal started,
you had them roughly tied. And Warnock has jumped
out to a roughly four point lead. And you see the
red line there is Walker. If you're looking
along with me, Walker's polling declining,
95% of the polling here is before the scandal.
So Monday, Tuesday, after the long weekend,
hopefully we will have some new data in which
it looks much, much worse for Herschel Walker.
And again, in a normal country, in a
normal planet, in a normal universe,
a galaxy, whatever, this guy would have no
shot. But this is not a normal situation.